all right denny
yeah danny where did you grow up where
are you from originally i was born in
oceanside and then we lived in uh poway
and then we moved up to salinas and then
sunnyvale and then back down to liquid
and then we moved to colorado when i was
14.
um
did mom and dad growing up
i was adopted when i was six months well
i was six months old when they found the
family that adopted me
um
and they are horrible people
ah
what was going on in your childhood
well so
i don't know the full story but i know
that
uh my dad was like dishonorably
discharged he was a commanding officer
um he was decoding the morse code that
the chinese were doing
in the late 70s i believe
maybe it was the 60s i don't remember
which one
but
uh
he got demoted and then forced retired
and then he opened school with my mom
and then that got shut down and
um i'm pretty sure that he was touching
me and my sister when we were kids but
she's their only daughter um
i was the adopted one but there's like
two years of my life where i never
knocked at my dad's door
and uh he opened the door and he had no
clothes on and then i have no memories
for about two years after that
um and they wanted a boy so they
basically
mean i knew i'd have sex by the time i
was three but i didn't know how to tie
my shoes until i was seven
yeah so like i i don't have any memories
for um two years after that he opened
the door like that
and um
on the level that they were like
they were abusive i mean emotionally
mentally but like
how i started running away from home
when i was six because
she's bad so
it was supposed to be an open adoption
and i found my dad when i was 15 but he
hung himself when i was 20.
so i didn't really get to know him and
my mom i never found her
up
when we moved
to colorado
mom and dad signed me over to dhs
custody
so i did two and a half years in juby
over a three dollar box of cop medicine
and um
then i got out
we got married and i had my oldest
and his dad moved in his ex-girlfriend
and said i could come home when she left
and
because i was 18 and he's 10 years older
than me and the judge said that she
couldn't take my son out of the only
home he'd ever been in
and give him to me because i was couch
surfing at the time
so then
it was um
october
um the following year and i
tried to kill myself and so
i froze to death and my best friend
found me
and
when they got me to the hospital my core
body temperature was 91 degrees
but i was i would have married matt if
he didn't get hit on his bike in a freak
accident
and so
he died nine months after saving my life
and then
and then my dad hung himself
and then
it's been like every six weeks is the
average that someone dies it's been
almost eight years now but my son and my
goddaughter were three weeks apart
oh my god
i was 27 weeks
when i had my son sam
and the umbilical cord was wrapped
around the placenta and so
if he'd lived he never would have walked
but like i don't know
how to be okay with it or
anything because i was his mom and i
couldn't save him or fix it
so my husband was the only person that
was there for me through all of that
but
um
october 1st was four years since sam
passed
and so after my first divorce
i got remarried
uh the following year and i had my
seven-year-old and he's autistic
and
he's just such a sweetheart
i have matthew my four-year-old
and
he's the one that my parents because
when sam died i gave
temporary rights to my parents for matt
because i wasn't good for myself and i
couldn't
and so
they got the sun they always wanted
and
and i got thrown to the curb
and it's like i've been with them my
whole life so they are my family you
know
but i have a
i have a very rare neurobiological
disorder called reactive attachment
disorder
when i was four months old um because i
was
my mom shot up the whole time she was
pregnant with me and
uh anyway so this
when she had me in the hospital they put
me into a foster home and when my
grandma came to get me at four months
old i wouldn't cry anymore i hadn't been
elder friends
so long
they didn't know what rad was until
about eight years ago
and uh if you catch it when when the
child is still a child you can fix it
but there isn't any fixing it for me
and my brain hijacks itself
when i get stressed out i just can't
handle it and so
and then i go
i don't remember usually anything that
happens but i destroy everything
everyone around me that matters to me
and
so the left side of my brain has 60 more
gray matter than it should
the right side has 20
less
you know
this was caused
is it genetic or is it
it's just from this i was four months
old and the foster home van
changed me or held me or fed me in so
long i wouldn't even cry anymore
and so it's from that
but whatever age
the child is
when the trauma happens
your brain in so many ways will be stuck
at that age and i was four months old
and so i was like
he's the only person that's ever stayed
in my life
everybody else leaves or they're gone
and
you guys have been married for how long
how long you been married
four years in september
but he's been in and out of jail a bunch
of
and i love it but
i don't know that things are going to
work because
i don't know
nothing has gone the way it was supposed
to and he's my best friend but he's the
only person i have
[Music]
and i didn't want to stay in colorado
and he just got back out of jail on the
first of this month so
i went back to nebraska to go get him
how long you guys been out here on
schedule
um
this time just for like almost a week
but we were we got stuck in vegas for
just over a week and it's illegal to be
out there on the streets or anything and
it was
it's really horrible and then
i have such bad ptsd that i have
schizophrenic tendencies when they
happen so i hear and see things that
aren't there that's because i've been
abused like
i've been sexually assaulted more times
than i've willingly done anything
but just always hurt me and he's the
only person that's ever kept me safe
i'm so sorry
all right take your time
do you want to continue
do you want to continue or
yeah okay
take your time
so
when i lost my son
i was to say well i got to the hospital
four days before
and they do the measurements with the
spine and the legs and
so they told me i was only like three
months old
and then if i was having miscarriages
nothing i could do so i went home and
then
and he was a baby and i didn't know what
to do and i couldn't fix it
i took him to my friend who's gonna bury
him on his family's farm and so then
before we
this was the first time that me and him
had come out to california together
i was staying at my friend's house and i
found my son in the freezer because he
didn't bury him
so
patrick
he buried it before me
he was the only person there for me and
so now i've been trying to figure out
how i'm supposed to be okay because
doesn't matter how much time goes by
that was my kid you know
normally i just bottle it all up because
it really stresses him out when i cried
so
i appreciate you
right now
do you forget to talk about this
do you ever get to talk about this with
anyone or
no because
i started to finally actually deal with
things from the last seven years when i
was staying with my grandma but it's
like
there's been so many people that have
died in
so many things and then i got sold first
to the cartel for a nineteen thousand
dollar jet i was drugged and raped by
nine people for three days
i don't have anybody left
except for him and i'm afraid of another
table
you're afraid of what
that i'm gonna lose him just like i've
lost everybody else
so i try and act like i'm fine but
i'm so not fine most of the time and i
just follow it all up and
i just want to be okay again you know
i know that we didn't really plan on
staying on the streets down here
my little sister my stepmom who's
married to my dad
i need to go see them
and they're open for two minutes
i feel like everything's crumbling all
around me and i don't know how to fix it
it's like
with my disorder it makes everything
impossible i can't get a normal job
and i don't do new people real well
it's like
i'm trying to figure out how to have
hope for something that they've said
there is no hope for
[Music]
but like
he gets mad if i bring up my son because
of
just the way all of it happened and
it messed him up just as bad as it
messed me up but
it's like i just keep it all buffalo
starting so i can't
and so then i talk about it when this
happens
and i just
where do you guys stay
we met this guy named james
just up the road so we would stay with
him but
i feel like we're intruding in last
night i had a panic attack and i was
like hearing voices and seeing people
and i really freaked him out
and so
i don't
know
you're saying you're staying in a tent
no with james at his apartment just up
on a
crescent
oh oh seven
but
we've been there since we got back to
town you know and so it's kind of like
i feel like we've overstayed our welcome
and
both me and him want to get on our way
north
to go see my little sister and my
nephews
i don't know
so then
the last six months
when i was back in colorado
i left there like a month ago
[Music]
also i have brain seizures sometimes i
got in the back of the head with a
hammer but i've had a few of those today
so i'm like
trying to reel my thoughts back in
i don't know what to do i don't know
where to go
i just feel like that
that's the only place me and him can go
because nobody supports us being
together
and
i mean
it's my mom and my little sister and so
i don't know
i just know that i can't do the street
thing
anymore because it's
in a matter of like a week i backslid
from
somewhat of a normal
being able to function
so now it's like i just keep falling
apart and crying and then everything is
so messed up
danny has are drugs of your
life i was sober until sam died
and then it's like
if i don't get i try to kill myself and
so
i've woken up in the icu 28 times
[Music]
i'm sick of it
i just want a normal life
i want to be sober and happy like i used
to be
you know what
and now i feel like
you have to take care of me you're
supposed to
i couldn't fix it i couldn't see it
i was like i really don't
i don't get high every day
you know
what is your drug that you do you do
clear usually
just because which is crystal meth just
because for a few minutes then it it
doesn't hurt me anymore nothing hurts me
anymore it's like i said be tall and i
don't have to feel any of it
it's like i understand that i don't want
to die and then she said i don't want to
feel this way but i don't know how to
get
it
have you been on psych medications
before
yeah i have gabby pitt and it's terrible
but i need to get them i need to call my
psychiatrist and schedule an appointment
again
but
i don't know
it's like i take the meds and then they
work for a little while and then
because of my attachment
disorder it's like i wake up one day
and everything is so horrible and then i
try to die because i
and so uh
so i don't really know
if i wanted to stay on the psych meds or
not because usually in the long run they
do more damage than good
uh
is there anything else you wanted to
know
i mean how how old are you i'm 27
27 have you been in this kind of
state for how long
situation
in this situation
um between
here in colorado and nebraska
majority of the last six years have been
like
what was the best time of your life
or have you had any
every time i think i'm starting to find
it or get better it's like everything
comes crashing down again
[Music]
my disorder with my brain it's like my
brain every day tells me i'm not good
enough and then i'm a burden
everyone's better off without me
then
does your husband help you
when you're having situations
they get too rough right
he tries but it's like
i don't know how to explain it other
than it's just not
and he doesn't mean to when it happens
so when we're not on the street
everything's fine but we're out here
it's like
i don't even know
because
it's like his eyes well dark and he
doesn't remember anything when it
happens
like
i don't know
i just want to help him and i want to
help me and i want to get better and i
don't know how to do it
ugh
is this the toughest period of your life
right now it's what has this been the
toughest period of your life right now
or
you've had a lot of tragedies
i keep
praying to god that something gives or
changes because i can't speak much more
you know it's like
i don't know actually ever been
i guess my second husband
we were married for two years and
we had our own motorcycle custom
motorcycles
riding saved my life and i had my
seven-year-old
but
um i mean his dad split up
he assaulted me and ripped my set out of
my arms
because i didn't talk to the cops i had
to go to jail and i lost everything
so i lost my son
and then he said my son over his parents
and
so i lost everything and then i take it
to trial because
i won but
i haven't seen jesse since he was three
and he's seven now
at my nine year old
i haven't seen him since he was 11
months old
so
i just want my kid
that would make everything better i feel
like
see i don't know how much i get more i
could do right now because
there's a very fine line of what i'm
safe for myself and i'm starting to go
over that edge like it's already been an
emotional few days
and
i just want to be okay
i don't know how to feel
do the psych medications help you
for a little while but then i wake up
but usually within six to nine months i
wake up and then i can't handle it so i
overdosed and then up in the ice team
it's like i don't know
i hate therapists because they're always
like well how do you feel about that or
like
oh yeah
oh
i'm so sorry i don't mean to fall apart
like this
take your time
yeah so i guess the only time i was ever
remotely like
i had to pick a time it would have been
when i had the motorcycle business i'm
sorry
uh
i'm sorry you were saying was there
anything else you
no i'm sorry dylan
see if you're having a hard time
with all of this
been kind of a long few days anyway
but i can't fall apart around here
and i didn't think i was gonna fall
apart like this
is your state always somewhat like this
or is this a bad bad moment
for you
is what is this a particularly bad time
right now for you or are you always kind
of in this state like this
uh the first day of this month was four
years since my son died
and then
the 25th will be my best friend's
birthday the one that passed away
the one that i was gonna marry
my dad
his anniversary is coming up and if he
wants
and then my god god passed away this
month four years ago too so
sorry
october's always bad
oh it's november isn't it
november
21st 20th
okay so october
[Music]
so i got tb i got hit the back of the
head and
back of my head with a hammer but my ex
has
so my short term is bad but i i have
brain seizures sometimes and i had a few
of those today so i'm like
stuck i think it's october is that
something
uh so yeah i guess it'd be last month
and i'm wrecked because
sometimes i'm a danger to myself so i
just
i just
had to get numb because i couldn't
because i can't deal with it anymore i
just don't and i know i don't want to
die and i know i don't want to hurt
myself so it's just like easier to just
numb it for a while
but i don't like doing that anymore i
just want to be okay
does your husband help you when you're
having weak moments like this
i'm sorry i don't fall apart around him
oh you don't
why is that does he get
does he handle it well it stresses him
out really bad and i think he might have
the same condition i have he just won't
go see
a therapist or anybody
to figure it out but
he almost killed me
it couldn't
he didn't
it's not his fault because
when your brain hijacks itself there's
nothing you can do to stop it you don't
remember what happens
but i try to keep
i didn't cry or talk about it for two
years when my son died because i
couldn't because i can't
because i have to make sure that i look
out for him and for me and so
and then
so much time would come by and so i was
questioning whether he and even that men
or if my son was even real
and so i asked him
you can't bring him up you can't talk to
me
[Music]
so i just dragged all the damnit all
this together you know the best i can
because he's got enough going on like in
january he got hit head-on on his
motorcycle
and we're in a two-ton workshop
he's gonna play his head
he's got enough going that's what i try
not to stress about or make things worse
it all explodes and everything is just
so awful
and then i started to realize oh i'm
gonna have to start like dealing with
these things to move on and move past it
but i don't know how because i try to i
start and then i
and then this happens it's like
so how am i supposed to deal with seven
years
going on eight years worth of like yes
the average is one every six weeks
everyone's gone
[Applause]
so because he's the only person i have
left
i just deal with
this stuff on my own
which means it just doesn't
really ever happen
[Music]
you